in other news the supreme court's
decisions upcoming decision on abortion
may have far-reaching consequences
especially in rural parts of america
where abortion axis is already very
limited 13 states have so-called trigger
laws making most abortions illegal if
the supreme court overturns the roe v
wade ruling which says women have a
constitutional right to abortion now one
of those states is wyoming where there
is strong opposition to abortion rights
and would-be providers have been met
with violence major garrett has that
story
much of wyoming looks like this
windswept and wide open
abortion in this conservative rugged
state is currently legal up to viability
usually 24 weeks of pregnancy but no
providers here offer surgical abortions
services have been lacking here julie
burkhardt is trying to change that just
as the supreme court considers rose fate
this is the waiting room her group
wellspring health access is behind the
effort to open this women's health
clinic in casper this month making it
the only abortion provider for hundreds
of miles but in late may it became a
crime scene it gets kind of messy over
here a fire ripped through the building
scalding its wall singing floor boards
and setting back the opening date as
much as six months long after the
supreme court's decision do i want to be
here talking about someone who committed
an act of domestic terrorism in our
building
absolutely not i wanted to be moving
furniture in the fire is being
investigated as arson surveillance video
shows the suspect carrying a gas can
into the waiting area in the middle of
the night
the clinic will offer a range of women's
health services including abortions if
they're still legal in wyoming whenever
it opens casper is strong pro-life
community so
don't expect
open arms
opposition to the clinic is vocal
blessed art thou among women each
thursday demonstrators like mike pyatt
gather outside to protest we've prayed
that some way the lord will prevent this
place from opening so if it happens to
be vandalism and a fire
i'm good with that i don't want this to
be in my city
this is a horrible evil wyoming's
republican legislature and governor
enacted a law in march that will ban
nearly all abortions if the supreme
court overturns roe versus wade the law
makes exceptions for cases of sexual
assault incest and for the physical
health of the mother
it won't shut down the clinic in casper
but it would still mean people like 24
year old hannah whose identity we've
concealed will have to seek care out of
state the pregnancy that i had
there was it was pretty much a death
sentence
hannah says her pregnancy earlier this
year worsened already complicated health
issues and she feared it could even kill
her i was withering away i was a wreck
of a human being if it would have been
an option to carry it to term
i would have so in february she drove
from her home in gillette wyoming seven
hours to a planned parenthood in montana
nearly 500 miles away any woman any
uterus holder who's had to have an
abortion does not think it's the easy
choice it's never the easy choice a
choice made that much harder by the
distance and expense
the new clinic is about two hours from
hannah's home right now there are six
states that have just one abortion
provider gail oklahoma currently has
none
boy major thank you very much